j'accueille maintenant michèle audette
l'ex président de l'association des
femmes autochtones du québec madame
odette ce jugement reconnaît donc le
canada a négligé ses enfants autochtones
c'est l'aboutissement d'une très longue
bataille qu'est ce que ça signifie qu
est ce que ça représente pour vous ça
représente beaucoup beaucoup de choses
ça représente un autre pan de l'histoire
que les gens n'ont pas connu pour
plusieurs raisons on a beaucoup entendu
parler des effets des écoles
résidentielles les pensionnats et
maintenant grâce au travail de la
société et de l'assemblée des premières
nations
enfin home et aux grands jockeys
toujours une discrimination comment on
ne traiter nos enfants dans les
communautés autochtones ici au canada
ouais il faut rappeler quand même que ça
n'a pas été facile le gouvernement
consorts conservateur s'est battu en
disant qu'on peut pas comparer en fait
les services qui étaient offerts aux
premières nations à ce qui était offert
aux restes du canadien
c'est exact alors ça donnait comme
impression pour les organismes et ceux
et celles qui militent pour cette
justice c'est comme si on avait deux
pays
ici au canada il ya celui où il ya le
tiers-monde alors on parle des
communautés autochtones dont la question
des déplacements de nos enfants et le
canada qui a déjà été
très bien placée au niveau de l' indice
de développement humain alors ses
carences et on l'a vu dans le reportage
elle touche en fait tous les domaines la
santé l'éducation les services sociaux
le logement vous qui êtes sur le terrain
concrètement comment ça se traduit ce
manque de services dans une réserve si
on est une communauté qu'on peut dire
semis et éloignées ou éloignés alors
c'est des communautés que ce l'avion le
train ou le lit ski-doo l'hiver écoutez
il ya un manque de ressources de
programmer deux structures en place la
volonté des gens et là par contre mais
c'est vraiment le soutien et si on va
dans les communautés beaucoup plus
urbaine alors on a accès aux programmes
et services que la ville peut offrir à
côté de notre communauté
donc faut penser à ceux et celles qui
vivent dans ces communautés là faut se
rappeler aussi que le canada le canada
le fédéral a un rôle foncier fiduciaire
et là il a complètement complètement mis
à part les enjeux auxquels on fait face
des services sociaux le placement
d'enfants donc la protection de la
jeunesse dans nos communautés
autochtones
mais est ce que vous pouvez me donner un
exemple concret peut-être que vous avez
vu
ce que j'ai vu à maintes reprises à
travers le canada
souvent nos enfants vont en voir été sur
évalué donc un placement très élevé à
l'extérieur de nos communautés sous
prétexte qu'on n'a pas les programmes
les structures où les nos familles sont
pas adéquates répond pas aux critères
alors que c'est pas vrai c'est je
voudrais que les familles qui sont très
simples d'esprit solide est prête à
accueillir ces enfants là dans le besoin
quand on parle aussi d'un manquement
tout le volet psychosocial pour soutenir
un travailleur social au québec je
comprends qu'on peut avoir ce que vous
avec moi mon anglais 23 caisse l'autre
alors que dans les communautés
autochtones on peut aller jusqu'à 30 à
37 caisses longue par travailleurs
sociaux dont parle du fardeau travail et
voilà et voilà donc on peut avoir un
roulement de personnel ils sont brûlés
fatigué et tout le volet comme je disais
psychosocial alors soutenir les familles
qui veulent garder ses enfants là où
garder leurs enfants
donc ça il ya un manquement et j'espère
que cette décision lève haut à mener
c'est ce qu'on a besoin d'eux alors on a
évalué que c'était ce manque à gagner à
ce sous financement ça représente
environ 200 millions de dollars par
année
si vous aviez cet argent là de vrais
matin qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ce
qu'est ce qui serait la priorité qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire de quoi est-ce
qu'ils ont besoin de plus ses enfants
écoutez moi j'encourage et je crois que
c'est le cas que madame bennett madame
ribot le ministre de la santé liste
responsable de toute la question
autochtone s'assoit avec
les gens qui ont lutté qui ont fait
avancer cette cause là ça soit aussi
avec les communautés parce qu'il ne faut
plus faire de politique du mur à mur en
pensant que tout le monde a la même
réalité pour penser à ceux du nord sud
sud l'est l'ouest du québec et si toutes
les provinces
une belle diversité alors si on veut que
ce soit une réussite faut s'asseoir avec
les gens qui sont sur le terrain
mais qu'est-ce que ça prendrait ça
prendrait plus de pyschologue plus de
travailleurs sociaux concrètement c'est
oui des travailleurs sociaux soutenir
nos travailleurs sociaux rappelons nous
que dans nos communautés souvent nos
travailleurs de première ligne deux
seront nés ont été aux autres aussi des
ex pensionnaires dans les écoles
résidentielles ou affectées par les
agressions sexuelles alors oui il faut
les soutenir soutenir les familles qui
veut se sortir de la toxicomanie ou de
la dépendance est évidemment soutenir
nos enfants tant à l'école que dans les
services sociaux
et ça ça va prendre du temps quand même
en pour faire pour remettre sur pied
tout à tout un système comme ça si une
volonté politique la part du fédéral ait
une volonté politique aussi des
gouvernements comme si au québec
je vous dirais que la volonté politique
autochtone elle est là donc si tout le
monde s'assoit ensemble et on met les
bonnes personnes autour de ce grand
cercle et de beaux petits miracles pour
arriver ouais vous pensez vraiment vous
êtes optimiste
oui je suis oui madame odette merci
beaucoup c'est moi qui vous remercie